alte sind ferien
da
bei mir
episode 3 ferienplanung
na schon pläne für die ferien
[Musik]
es ist bereits 12 uhr
ja und ja wir müssen essen gehen ans
buffet recht jetzt das ist halt voll
tension com
ich habe sowieso kein hunger
das ist eine frage des prinzips
die haben dafür bezahlt also müssen wir
auch essen
praxis punkt ch
wo sollen wir ferien machen
nur nicht weder kämpen wie letztes jahr
nur nicht wieder kempten wie letztes
jahr
das internet auf dem
platz war so langsam
das internet auf dem campingplatz war so
langsam
es hat also viele mücken
es hatte
die lücken
du wolltest doch immer fordern mädchen
angeben
du wolltest doch immer vor den mädchen
stimmt gar nicht wäre ich vor allen
leuten in den bach gefallen
stimmt das
wer es vor allen leuten in den bach
gefallen
hh
die frage ist doch wo wir dieses jahr
ferien machen sollen
ich möchte wieder einmal ans meer aber
sicherlich mit dem flugzeug
ich möchte wieder einmal ans meer
aber sicher nicht mit dem flugzeug
dieses schild es so erbärmlich wie
unsere klima politik
sollen die doch demonstrieren und vor
allem weniger fliegen
dann können wir oben schossen
verbrauchen
bis 4
sind wird sich sowieso nichts ändern
die haben die macht
sollen die doch demonstrieren und vor
allem weniger fliegen
dann können wir oben schon mehr
ressourcen verbrauchen
bisher gestorben sind wird sich sowieso
nichts ändern
wir haben die macht to hh
wir könnten mit dem zug an nordsee
fahren
hier hatte seine anzeige
wir könnten mit dem zug an die nordsee
fahren
hier hat das
eine anzeige
ferien auf sylt attraktiver
ferienwohnung mit segelboot auf der
nördlichsten deutschen insel
was wollen sie mehr
ferien auf sylt attraktive ferienwohnung
mit segelboot auf der nördlichsten
deutschen insel
was wollen sie mehr
wir können doch gar nicht segeln
hatte seinen wasser
wag
hatte seinen wasserpark
hat das internet
hat es internet
oder hier in
die m
ferienwohnung am strand drei zimmer
wohnung mit blick auf die adria
5 gehminuten vom öffentlichen strand von
rimini preisgünstig zu vermieten im
august
ferienwohnung am strand
drei zimmer wohnung mit blick auf die
adria
5 gehminuten vom öffentlichen strand
preisgünstig zu vermieten im august
kann man dieses jahr nach italien reisen
[Musik]
stimmt dieses jahr ist alles ein
bisschen kompliziert stimmt dieses jahr
ist alles ein bisschen kompliziert
kommt wir bleiben in der schweiz
hier ist es auch schön
wie gesagt einfach kein camping
wie gesagt einfach kein camp
peng
ich möchte fischen
und ich möchte warten
ich möchte wieder einmal in die berge
ich möchte fischen
und ich möchte baden
ich möchte wieder einmal in die
danke
vielleicht wäre das hier was
glamping am thunersee bieten sie eines
unserer bungalows mit fünf betten
komplette küche eigener terrasse mit
schöner aussicht auf eiger mönch und
jungfrau
glamping am thunersee
bieten sie eines unserer bungalows
mit fünf betten
mit kompletter köche
mit eigener
mit schöner aussicht auf eiger mönch und
jungfrau
das ist ja fast wie camping
oder dass hier die fischers lodge am weg
thaler sie
das sieht ja toll aus
die zimmer haben einen
wunderschöne aussicht
die zimmer haben eine wunderschöne
aussicht
perfekt es ist in den bergen und im see
kann man fischen und baden
perfekt es ist in den bergen und dem see
das buchen wir
[Musik]
oh nein die familie schröder kommt in
die fischer slot
fort
folgt wenn du wissen willst wie es
weitergeht dann das video
[Musik]
danke wir schauen
möchtest du gratis online deutsch lernen
mehr als 200 video lektionen abonniere
unseren kanal möchtest du gratis online
deutsch lernen mehr als 200 video
lektionen abonniere unseren kanal